et pourquoi le PSG gagne plus en fait
pour qu'il ne gagne plus le PSG
interview vérité
[Musique]
ça faites chaud Laurent Baffie cette
déchirer la gueule
non pas du tout Louis en 96 vous
déclariez à l'équipe magazine
j'attendrai le temps qu'il faudra mais
je suis convaincu que je reviendrai au
PSG aujourd'hui vous regrettez d'être
revenu au PSG quelque part quelque chose
que je l'avais pensé je l'avais imaginé
peut-être pas si rapidement que ça parce
qu'après avoir passé quatre années comme
celle que j'ai passé en Espagne avoir
vécu dans un championnat comme le
championnat espagnol je m'étais donné
une année sabbatique un peu dans le dans
ce monde qui est un peu un monde et le
milieu football qui a énormément bougé
il y a beaucoup de choses qui qui
bougent bon maintenant
il fait partie de moi alors est-ce que
vous vivez la plus mauvaise période de
votre carrière d'entraîneur non
non non parce qu'il y a des moments
difficiles tu sais éventuellement la
télé ça arrive aussi oui mais dans les
huit années d'entraîneur depuis le début
parfois j'ai eu des moments difficiles
et que bon bah les gens ne sont pas
censés savoir ne pas connaître à moins
de bien savoir les passer ces moments-là
et pourquoi le PSG gagne plus en fait
pour créer une gagne plus le PSG je
crois qu'il y a eu quand on voit un peu
la situation du club et on voit un peu
ces dix dernières années et à chaque
année il y a toujours un une période un
peu délicate un peu difficile et le club
a toujours son mauvais passage et qu'on
arrive pas à relativement à essayer de
trouver la solution à moi et je pense
que personnellement j'ai quelques idées
là-dessus bien alors quand lors de la
défaite le 10 février à Auxerre vous
avez déclaré que c'est une peut-être de
la malchance je vais parler de corbeau
et de chat noir et c'est vrai que le 20
février contre le Milan AC égalisation à
dernière minute il y a un mauvais sort
contre le PSG je ne dirais pas qu'il y a
un mauvais sort il y a il y a on peut
dire que dans le sport il y a des il y a
des comme ça qu'il faut savoir analyser
qu'il faut savoir essayer de comprendre
même si parfois on essaie de se dire bon
on a trouvé une solution mais que le
football le sport en général il y a rien
qui et que ça aussi ça fait partie dans
le football de ces moments difficiles
qu'une équipe peut traverser parce que
Laurent Ruquier a essayé de désenvoûter
le PSG dans son émission mardi dernier
il l'a presque réussi il a presque
réussi oui il a presque réussi parce
qu'on continue alors oui moi il a
presque réussi parce qu'on a fait un bon
match face à Milan
et on dirait je dirais plutôt que c'est
sur ces matchs là qu'on travaille un peu
sur pour l'avenir alors pour en venir à
la Ligue des Champions compte tenu des
performances actuelles de l'équipe
est-ce que vous croyez vraiment que ces
deux victoires en deux matchs sont
possibles oui oui tout est possible je
dirais que quand on voit l'équipe
réalisée de bon match face au Milan AC
en y mettant de la qualité on y mettant
en état d'esprit on dit que la Coupe
d'Europe ça c'est un parfum un peu
spécial ça les joueurs aiment cette
compétition là
il la joue parce qu'ils savent que c'est
un peu le la vitrine c'est à dire que
ces joueurs là du PSG ils se battent que
quand c'est des trucs un peu valorisant
la Ligue des Champions ça c'est
la Ligue des Champions ça se transforme
ça ça motive ça c'est quelque part c'est
c'est regarder dans dans le monde entier
et on a tous envie de gagner de la Ligue
des Champions c'est la Coupe d'Europe
c'est le c'est un des objectifs bon
c'est peut-être pas celui du PSG cette
année c'était peut-être d'arriver en
quart de finale alors il faut
éventuellement y penser à La Corogne
contre La Corogne avec le PSG de toute
façon c'est pour ça que vous dites on
peut y arriver on peut y arriver non
c'est pas ce que j'ai gagné là-bas c'est
que je crois que l'effectif ou l'équipe
en réalisant ce qu'elle a réalisé ces
derniers temps elle est capable de
gagner à La Corogne est-ce qu'ils sont
pas trop payé trop gâtés les joueurs du
PSG aujourd'hui je ne dirais pas je le
dirai pas comme ça je dirais que le
football en depuis la loi Bosman depuis
le c'est ces changements ces derniers
temps il y a un bouleversement des
données et il faudrait s'y pencher mais
bon ce des artistes les garçons qui
essayent de faire le mieux possible si
on dit qu'on est trop payé dans le
milieu de football je dirais que dans
d'autres professions aussi on est trop
payé réellement
bien pourquoi vous changez si souvent
Louis la formation de l'équipe je
comprends pas moi il y a quand même
énormément de compétitions quand tu as
un effectif surtout quand on a un comme
celui que tu as au Paris Saint-Germain
tu as 20 25 jours qui sont relativement
où il y a de la qualité tu es obligé de
faire un tourneur l'entraîneur Nanterre
Reynald de nouaks le disait il y a pas
très longtemps et pourtant il est
deuxième du championnat avec des options
de gagner la Coupe de France la Coupe de
la Ligue il est en Coupe d'Europe il est
en championnat alors il est dans le vrai
et je pense aussi comme lui que quand tu
as beaucoup de compétitions il faut
aussi penser à faire tourner un peu ton
infusion alors quand tu gagnes personne
et quand tu perds
il y a beaucoup de changements ça change
alors quand on parle maintenant on va te
dire aussi sur la tactique tu changes
souvent de système tactique tu joues
avec trois avec quatre avec cinq les
joueurs sont un peu perdus mais ils sont
censés être professionnel aussi le
joueur doit s'adapter à toutes les
situations c'est un entraîneur doit
s'adapter si contre le Milan AC je
m'aperçois que je joue dans un système
et que ça se passe mal à moins
d'interpréter le jeu moins de changer et
le jour est capable d'analyser qu'il
faut changer le joueur a su le faire
face à Milan c'est en ce moment on
rentre un peu dans ces dans ces systèmes
et les médias veulent savoir aussi quand
je le vois à la télé sur le banc de
touche c'est un vrai spectacle que de le
voir et parce que en tout cas il
est son match il a l'air sincère dans
dans ce qu'il fait mais là l'image qu'on
a vu tout à l'heure là c'était
magnifique
je suis détruit je suis euh ça me fait
mal pour les joueurs parce qu'il le
méritent pas il mérite pas de prendre un
but comme ça dans la minute quand on
voit ce qu'ils ont réalisé durant 90
autant je peux être déçu après le match
de Guingamp de la deuxième mi-temps
lorsqu'on perd 3 à la maison je peux
être déçu parce que parce que c'est
comportement peut-être il y a eu un
relâchement et après une après un match
nul comme celui de façon Milan
contemporain but tout ça
match nul en ce moment c'est bon à
prendre parce que j'ai vu quelque part
tous les soirs quand tu commences il dit
encore un jour sans que le PG ait gagné
ouais c'est dur alors est-ce que
pourquoi vous n'obligez pas parler à la
presse les médias se sont acharnés un
peu sur Nicolas
je voudrais bon dire que Nicolas c'est
quand on le connaît bien quand on le
voit vivre au sein d'un groupe c'est
quelqu'un de très il est charmant il est
il est sympa il est en plus de ça
qui est justement contrairement à ça
quand il va en Espagne et qui fait un
contrat de 7 ans il n'a pas eu revenir
un an après au Paris Saint-Germain parce
que il peut rester 7 ans là-bas et
éventuellement il peut se mettre
vraiment tranquillement jusqu'à la fin
de ses jours pour te dire ce qu'il a
laissé là-bas pour revenir jouer en
France
moins ouais vous avez une carrière
beaucoup plus longue la nôtre est très
courte
sur une dizaine d'années mais on en
gagne que pendant cinq six ans sinon les
cinq premières années tu gagnes presque
rien du tout
l'année prochaine si vous n'êtes pas bon
si vous n'êtes pas en couple d'Europe
vous allez gardez un LK quand même ah
bon je suis parti de ces garçons sur
lesquels on compte je crois que moi
aussi Paris c'est quand même un grand
club quand même c'est un club qui qui
fait rêver club qui est en Europe quand
on parle du Paris-Saint-Germain en
Espagne c'est un globe qui qui aspire à
être hyper considéré et en Espagne une
bonne cote le PSG donc maintenant c'est
non pourquoi le PSG c'est très connu en
France
il y a pas de problème bien est-ce que
Laurent perpaire est compétent comme
président
comme ça je dirais qu'il est différent
il a sa méthode est quand même quelqu'un
qui laisse travailler son entraîneur et
qu'il le laisse faire ce qu'il a à faire
et que il me laisse travailler
tranquillement alors les supporters ils
sont pas contents oui je les ai
rencontrés il y a pas très longtemps ils
sont pas contents
ils ont fait une banderole avec WW point
équipe de merde.fr
souvent il y en a qui se cache et qui
restent chez eux qu'est-ce qu'il leur a
dit le président était ensemble on s'est
retrouvé avec 3400 supporters on leur a
expliqué on leur a donné des raisons de
bon ben que la citation n'était pas au
mieux c'est normal qu'il soit déçu mais
il faut qu'on reste solidaire donc on
reste unis pour s'en sortir de 13% donc
il faudrait quand même verrouiller
l'histoire maintenant on verra bien
alors maintenant chez vous vous éteignez
la lumière et je réponds à Laurent Asti
pas la télé c'est un mec qui me dit
quand on fait la question qui tue on
éteint la lumière mais ce qu'on doit
éteindre la télé non on est un que la
lumière Laurent et ici aussi
voilà
c'est chaud là oh c'est chaud Luis
Fernandez
serez-vous encore entraîneur du PSG la
saison prochaine parce qu'après du
contraire oui même si vous perdez tous
les matchs qui viennent là non je ne
souhaite pas perdre et je pense qu'on ne
perdra pas tous les matchs qui restent
on va en gagner on va on va remonter on
va on va se resituer dans une position
qui sera un peu plus honorable pour le
Paris Saint-Germain et pour tous ceux
qui aiment le Paris Saint-Germain merci
on l'a vu
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu